[Music]
this film is so wild what was your first
reaction when you first read the script
um what I I had to read it a good few
times to really wrap my head around
everything I was dealing with yes thank
you
no actually I was just leaving no never
leaves I think it's the kind of film
that really you're at the edge of your
seat the whole time I think it's the
sort of film that you're gonna have to
watch again to really pick up another
details and you know you're probably
going to be really creeped out for a few
days yeah for sure you're married to one
of the best actors in Hollywood I was
curious when you have such an amazing
actor as your partner how much you guys
are able to help each other yes he's
definitely um one of the most brilliant
actors for sure um I'm incredibly proud
of him and I have great respect for him
I try to UM you know to keep my private
life private and just stick to the left
and what's up next for you I'm about to
go shoot a movie called high life um and
I play a convict and there's a bunch of
us and we get sent to space and to
explore black holes and reproductive
possibilities
[Music]
you